i want to talk a little bit about a
piece that joel mathis wrote
in the week about how donald trump just
can't stand that joe biden is stealing
the spotlight
from him and trump's been hiding out at
the white house and at his golf courses
but that's actually making the problem
even worse
and joel mathis in his piece likens it
to norma desmond
in sunset boulevard and you might
remember in sunset boulevard norma
desmond is
she ends up long after she is no longer
you know the hollywood star that she
once was she's surrounded by sycophants
and enablers and yes men and yes women
long after she stops commanding any
respect sort of living
out a fantasy living out a fake
existence for lack of a better term
and the point the analogy here is that
donald trump's behavior
only makes sense if you go beyond
questions like could this strategy work
to steal the election from joe biden
does trump really think that he actually
won
pennsylvania once you get beyond those
initial questions
and you go to well what trump is doing
here is desperately trying to
cling to the spotlight both for ego and
vanity
as much as fears of being investigated
and potentially prosecuted after he's
out of office
that's the framework in which this
starts to make sense
and the more that the spotlight turns
towards joe biden
the angrier that donald trump gets which
explains his tweets over the weekend
saying
why is joe biden forming a cabinet why
is joe biden moving ahead
when we still are fighting this and we
actually won
and the reality is that this is when the
spotlight should be turning to joe biden
for two reasons
number one in general when you have a
new president-elect
the president that's outgoing is called
a lame duck president that's because
while they are still president
the next four years are going to be
decided upon
from an executive from the executive
branch standpoint
by joe biden not by donald trump and so
donald trump has these waning days
during which he is president so
in general the attention now turns to
the president-elect
what is the cabinet going to look like
what are the day one priorities what are
the hundred days
day priorities etc but donald trump is
exacerbating the speed
at which the spotlight is turning to joe
biden
because donald trump isn't even working
anymore trump
stopped doing presidential work months
before the election
he was uh just campaigning not dealing
with coronavirus
not getting his pdb's presidential daily
briefings
and he's barely been seen in public
since the election he's scheduled to do
some kind of turkey thing today related
to thanksgiving
he's not actually taking questions since
the election it's probably been about a
month
since he's taken press questions we have
a hundred year pandemic
which trump all but ignored and joe
biden has a coronavirus task force
and is taking it seriously so of course
americans in the media are turning to
joe biden
if you look at joe biden and trump only
one of them is still dealing with
coronavirus or
is dealing with coronavirus and it's joe
biden so who are you going to turn to
joe biden is the one choosing a cabinet
that is going to have to lead us out of
this mess economically
and from a public health standpoint so
of course that's what we're talking
about
and evaluating is joe biden making the
right choices or not and how are these
people going to govern
that joe biden is selecting so when
trump
doesn't recognize biden's win finally
now allowing the formal transition to
start
which is the closest we're going to get
to a concession from trump while still
claiming that he actually won
he is desperately trying to cling not
just to the presidency
but to the spotlight because of his ego
and his narcissism and joel mathis does
point
out that some of this
is the media's fault by continuing to
talk about
joe biden's apparent victory and the
network
uh uh the the networks like oan and
newsmax
not even using the term apparent victor
and just placating any insane notion
about donald trump being the actual
winner
they do encourage the system to keep it
going
but it's mostly donald trump and we know
trump hates being ridiculed
we know trump hates being mocked and we
saw that with his quick distancing from
that
whacked out lawyer sidney powell when
she went on newsmax
and said there would be evidence of
biblical proportions soon to prove fraud
she was instantly fired and in fact it
was one of these retroactive she never
really was working for us anyway
because the mockery is what got to
donald trump that does actually get to
him so
it's possible that more mockery of trump
will get him to more maybe to actually
use the term i concede and call joe
biden
but all that really matters is that
donald trump yesterday did finally say
via twitter
i'm allowing the transition to happen
formally even though i'm going to keep
fighting
and um eventually donald trump will
leave regardless
joe biden will still become president
but it's going to be all the more
embarrassing for donald trump
in the meantime the best we can do is
all move on to talking about joe biden's
plans
his cabinet selections his coronavirus
task force
and we're doing it and i have to tell
you i
am as i've said before trump
would be better another four years of
trump would be better for the business
of the david pakman show there's no
doubt it would be worse for the country
and i am actually enjoying starting to
look into
the backgrounds of joe biden's cabinet
picks
what is joe biden likely to do on day
one via executive order
what is biden going to do in his first
week in terms of the virus
what are the first hundred day
priorities how is biden's
secretary of homeland security going to
deal with
immigration policy we're actually
getting back
into substance and i heard from a bunch
of people yesterday longtime viewers of
the show who have said
i you know i've been a fan for a long
time i love what you do
but i am already feeling a breath of
fresh air and just getting back to
talking about policy even if we don't
agree with everything joe biden does
certainly we will not uh the guy who
looked at the solar eclipse
his time is up the guy who suggested
bleach injections
sort of like a cleaning to treat the
virus he is going to be leaving the guy
who used the sharpie
to adjust a hurricane map for political
gain
he is exiting stage left in eight weeks
and we are all the better for it
and we are we are going to continue
moving forward and i am glad to say
that uh hopefully progressive media is
on the path
to becoming dramatically more
substantive
as we get closer and closer to joe
biden's swearing-in
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show
and while you're there you can follow me
on instagram
at david.pakman as well one of our
sponsors today is
lucy and they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical